SHOULD TRANSGENDERS ATHLETES IN
HIGH SCHOOL BE ALLOWED?
THIS IS "SPECIAL REPORT."
>> Shannon: I AM SHANNON BREAM
IN FOR BRET BAIER.
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S COMMENTS THAT
HE DOESN'T BELIEVE NORTH KOREA'S
KIM JONG-UN WAS AWARE OF THE
MISTREATMENT THAT LED TO THE
DEATH OF AN AMERICAN COLLEGE
STUDENT IS GETTING MAJOR PUSH
BACK FROM THE MAN'S PRESENTS.
THEY SAID KIM IS RESPONSIBLE.
THE PRESIDENT TRIED TO EXPLAIN
HIMSELF.
MIKE EMANUEL IS AT THE WHITE
HOUSE AS THE PRESIDENT GETS BACK
TO BUSINESS AFTER A
DISAPPOINTING SUMMIT IN VIETNAM.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP IS ON THE
DEFENSE ABOUT THE COMMENTS ABOUT
THE DEATH OF OTTO WARMBIER.
HE IS BLAMING NORTH KOREA BUT
NOT CALLING OUT THEIR LEADER.
ON TWITTER PRESIDENT TRUMP TRIED
TO CLARIFY.
OF COURSE I HOLD NORTH KOREA
RESPONSIBLE.
IN VIETNAM THE PRESIDENT DID NOT
BLAME KIM JONG-UN.
>> I BELIEVE SOMETHING VERY BAD
HAPPENED TO HIM.
I DON'T THINK THE TOP LEADERSHIP
KNEW ABOUT IT.
>> THE PARENTS OF OTTO WARMBIER
DISAGREED WITH THE PRESIDENT
SAYING KIM AND HIS EVIL REGIME
ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR THE DEATH OF
OUR SON OTTO WARMBIER AND FOR
UNIMAGINABLE CRUELTY AND
INHUMANITY.
NO LAVISH PRAISE CAN CHANGE
THAT.
THE PRESIDENT TOOK HEAT FROM
BOTH SIDES.
>> KIM JONG-UN KNOWS EVERYTHING
THAT HAPPENS IN HIS COUNTRY,
CERTAINLY WITH RESPECT TO AN
AMERICAN BEING HELD PRISON
THERE.
>> WE SHOULD NOT BE NAIVE ABOUT
THIS REGIME AND THE WAY THEY
MISTREAT THEIR OWN PEOPLE AND
MISTREATED OTTO WARMBIER.
>> IN VIETNAM, PRESIDENT TRUMP
FIXER MICHAEL COHEN TESTIFY ON
CAPITOL HILL.
PRESIDENT TRUMP WENT AFTER HIM
ON TWITTER.
COHEN'S ATTORNEY SAID THE
PRESIDENT WAS LYING.
ADDING SOMETIME IN EARLY 2018
MR. COHEN WAS OFFERED AN ADVANCE
FOR A PROPOSAL REGARDING A BOOK
ON UNDERSTANDING DONALD TRUMP.
THIS IS JUST THE BEGINNING.
COHEN DUE BACK ON CAPITOL HILL
MARCH 6th.
THE EXECUTIVE WHO WORKED ON A
PROPOSED DEAL TO BUILD A TRUMP
TOWER IN MOSCOW WILL TESTIFY AND
THEY WILL CALL TRUMP FAMILY
NUMBERS LIKE IVANKA AND JARED
KUSHNER.
>> THE DEMOCRAT'S INTENTION IS
FOR THIS INVESTIGATION GO INTO
2020 AND INTO THE NEXT ELECTION.
IF THEY DON'T FIND EVIDENCE OF
COLLUSION, WHICH THEY HAVE NOT,
THEY WILL LOOK FOR SOMETHING
ELSE.
>> THE "NEW YORK TIMES" SAID THE
PRESIDENT OVER RULED HIS WHITE
HOUSE CHIEF OF STAFF DEMANDING A
TOP SECRET CLEARANCE FOR SENIOR
ADVISOR KUSHNER.
IT ALARMED SENIOR OFFICIALS.
THERE WAS AN INTERNAL MEMO ABOUT
THE MATTER.
THE PRESIDENT DENIED GETTING
INVOLVED IN THE SECURITY
CLEARANCE ISSUE WRITING I AM NOT
TRYING TO GET TOP LEVEL SECURITY
CLEARANCE FOR MY CHILDREN.
THIS IS A FALSE NEWS STORY.
CUMMINGS DEMANDED ANSWERS FROM
THE WHITE HOUSE TOP LAWYER.
THE WHITE HOUSE ADVISORS DO NOT
TALK ABOUT SECURITY CLEARANCES